why I like these seasons the most
because it does tackle the hardship now
we have that very like at-home style
where cameras follow us for longer and
catch us better like highs and lows
JWoww is getting candid that's Grayson
her four year old son
Jenny revealed he was diagnosed with
autism last fall and so isn't
understanding a lot of words he's
honestly the best I think I had to leave
a dude ranch to go to one of his
diagnosing appointments like literally
in the middle of the night these days
he's doing great
oh yeah where he went from nonverbal not
even knowing his name to today where
he's attempting like full sentences he
has a personality he's really just leaps
and bounds has come so far and with all
his therapies and stuff like to go back
like that's what's exciting for me a day
less than a year later see how far he's
come
JWoww will talk about her son on the new
season of Jersey Shore family vacation
premiering Thursday July 11 the biggest
thing with the platform and Grayson is
and I know a lot of people that try and
like deny or like question on the rug or
like to start to think about it is
speaking about anything especially like
autism can break this stigma and that's
my biggest thing that I want to do right
now because there is such a big stigma
but there's also a big population of
kids getting diagnosed so I just want to
make the world a little less harsh and
more sweet so when he goes to school
there'll be less critics and actually
like more people that want to help and
you know understand what it's like to
have autism
so that's my goal